[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's the new intro for us
the experts and we have anthony lee here
a dancing expert a professional dancer
and a tantric sex expert oh really
yeah just put on my linkedin tantric sex
you're gonna have to teach us about that
that's me and steve but not for each
other
wait why not for each other
we learned the tantric arts who's
financial advisors and tantric sex
experts
it's about you tell us how do you how
did you start a good anal [ __ ]
lube okay next question when did you
decide you wanted to be a dancer
we need to get john cnn i should have
[ __ ] oprah dude i should have [ __ ]
uh interviewed meghan markle
why i got bird shirt we're bursting on
your [ __ ] shoulder
oh that you saw that meme i recently saw
that one too she has bertrand no they
they like memed it where it looks like
there's birds oh guys we're getting
distracted that wasn't
what made you want to be a dancer
when you started this art of dance when
did you know like this is my
this is it i'm gonna this
is my [ __ ] money maker
that's it food no other life for me i'm
saving the rec center
the rec center [ __ ] every time with the
rec center
[Laughter]
i think i i i definitely got a chance to
build a relationship and fall in love
with dancing in college but it was
not ever a forethought in my mind to be
like this is going to be my career i was
i was a film and media
uh studies major in college at uci um
so you didn't you started dancing in
high school or basically in college
yeah the kaaba sutra group no no that's
called a monster
okay and they were actually the kind of
like if anything the
crosstown rival dance team that um was
the rival of the team that i ended up
joining um i joined a team called cadc
in my second year college my first year
of college i was still learning how to
dance so i joined the uci b-boy club
so like breaking was like my first thing
that i got into well before that
what made you even get into that because
no one in the right mind in college
wants to learn how to b-boy
[Laughter]
you know at that time though like we had
um there was like a small click of uh
like filipinos that were breaking
at uh my high school sunny hills but the
amount of people that were dancing at
that time
um especially guys was so it was like
taboo honestly straight up if guys were
dancing back then it was like
kind of gay you know what i mean that's
just how people thought about it and so
um i remember my sister who even b boys
i always felt like b-boys
had a little bit more respect than like
yeah
but then like in in high school you see
a lot of dudes trying to be b-boys right
like just trying to do a bunch of like
handstands or like windows
aren't really continuous they're just
kind of like rolling all over the place
and kicking their legs
yeah i was one of them um but the point
is like uh
it was just not as present and you
didn't like receive it on things like
social media so it wasn't just like
known that like people would do this and
then i would look at the dance
production team at my high school which
my sister was on it's all girls like
very jazzy type stuff right
but i was always copying michael
jackson's [ __ ] at home like uh
in my socks trying to like moonwalk and
stuff like that and just always listen
to mj
so my sister realized that i liked
dancing so she uh made me
mj in college in high school high school
so no training just like literally just
trying to do that my sister like brought
me to a dance
workshop at high school and i was the
only boy there and i remember being
so embarrassed but she already signed me
up and
i don't remember who it was but i
actually started teaching some
choreography
and so we have to learn it and i'm just
the one little kid
and all these girls in dance production
and i just started having hella fun
and that was my only experience of it
like outside of me trying to imitate
stuff so i just i think that was like
really
uh the first real seat it was my sister
but then there was no outlet that like
felt socially like appropriate or
acceptable and
i also like was you know an idiot and
didn't understand like how
things worked in the world you should
keep going back to those workshops no no
it's just a
i wasn't in that production and my
sister just brought me but when i got to
college
and welcoming suddenly you start seeing
like all the organizations on like you
know the railroad and stuff like that
there's like
fraternities everybody's kind of just
out social you see dance performances
and you see these huge teams of like 30
people
and like especially as a freshman coming
into like a college where suddenly like
you know
yeah it's huge yeah you see like a dance
team i remember seeing cdc my dance team
you know there's a bunch of dudes and
girls dancing and the dudes
look straight they look dope they look
cool and the girls are like
from afar i'm like they're hot suddenly
you're like far
well i mean you because you don't know
you're just sitting there you're like
whoa this is this is hot right
yeah he's like girls routines [ __ ]
dancing what was at the time like
pushing all my buttons baby i'm so sorry
our goodies not my goodness those are
some of the numbers that i was watching
as a freshman
yeah and then suddenly it's like okay
this thing is cool
and i wanted to learn how to dance you
know but again just to answer your
question
none of that had anything to do with a
career it was a career
you just liked it so if i were to uh
fast forward
it was in after college i went into like
a sales job and all this stuff and then
uh
after the sales job like i quit that and
then i worked for a tech company
for like a month my boy who hired me and
after that i got recruited to
work in the sales and marketing
department of street clothing brand
and then um one thing led to another
and life just didn't really work out and
i i actually had to uh get let go from
the company
um so it wasn't actually until in that
same year 2000
10 or 11 2011. i think it was 2011 that
same year
10 years ago i got uh let go
from my company i also broke with my
girlfriend at that time and i moved back
home
so like you know a couple years after
college i'm like back home with my
parents i got like no money in the bank
um you know what i mean and just a
little heartbroken so i i
think it was rock bottom that allowed me
to
kind of figure out what dance really
meant to me because it was like you know
back then
like when you need to get a job again
you're going like monster.com and you're
like signing up for [ __ ]
the [ __ ] worst trying to send your
res first of all redoing your resume
like four years after college like
that should just is like [ __ ] with
your psyche then you're sending it out
and you're sitting there and people were
just like you know why do you want to
work for this company and like i'm
i'm capable of like lying but like i
don't really like to so they're
i remember this one interview literally
like stu is like why do you want to work
for this company and i was like
i don't know oh
[ __ ] wow it is it is but at the same
time it was like
it was it was like the thing that i was
like
uh oh not about this then i and and so
i shook his hand and i left i was like
my bad and then i left and then
the the most ironic thing is in my like
frustration and when i felt like i had
no control when i had like no money and
stuff like that
the only thing i could do to like feel
yeah like in control of life was like
dancing
save your own rec center in here
because they're taking away this rec
center that's what they
couldn't take away oh yes bro um so i
remember
just having like three four hour
sessions in my in my
parents home you know my socks and stuff
because i was like that was my own
i thought your dad don't love you
all about the hell no and then your
mom's on facebook all the [ __ ] white
socks i gotta scrub myself
just jump straight to that's why your
dad don't love you there's no in between
during this time did your did your
parents have any input on like the
direction
they thought i was still just applying
for [ __ ] so like it wasn't like uh
a disappointment you know what i mean
it's kind of like oh yeah i'm putting
together my resume blah blah
um you're dancing me dude
you know be funny if like 10 years from
now you find out your dad was like this
dancer in vietnam and [ __ ]
and he's all like oh you kept like you
caught him doing the [ __ ] cha-cha and
[ __ ] you're like you catch me
no and i'll be like we could have gone
viral on tick-tock together no he goes
no
those days are over but everybody can
smile when they dance with their parents
look at mike look at what happened to
mike and his mom i know you should have
kept those things up
and you partnered with me instead ah she
doesn't my mom my mom dad's by herself
oh yeah but your mom dance is better
than you i know she is that's even
better
it's even more viral yeah it's even
better
to disco yeah so i think uh just having
those moments
in like when nothing else was around
like dance was kind of like to be
i guess semi-cheese it was the thing
that like saved me um
i feel like being able to for me uh
choreographing creating is my favorite
part about dancing
so being able to create um in that time
was really important for me because like
i could create something and yeah nobody
could take that away and nobody can
judge it right
i guess everybody could judge it but
then right after that because i was
creating and i had no money
um i would hit up a couple local dance
studios and be like yo
you think i could teach class and they
knew who i was because i was dancing as
a hobby in college
so i'd get classes for like 20 bucks
this was huge at the time to get paid 20
bucks to like teach something that i
made up was like that's so cool
the most incredible feeling and uh you
know you have a little bit of buzz
because you were in a crew so they're
like okay
yeah that's the only reason why if
anything get hired by certain dance
studios
i see and they'll give me like a 20
class you know once a week
and i in my mind literally at the time i
was like all right if i get 80 bucks a
month that's my cell phone bill that's a
start
and then eventually one thing that done
i was like let me pick up um
well actually and then the next most
important moment was talking to my son
my song at the time had just gone off at
abdc in 2008
and so like for the first time ever i
was seeing like this
group of asians [ __ ] going around the
world not being like
janet jackson's tour dancers or like
what it was like just
them they were like cobble modern and
their their faces were on the fly and
then people were taking their class the
class would be like
mike song blah blah blah it wouldn't be
just like
this person choreography industry
hip-hop whatever you'd be like
them you want to learn them you can go
learn them hey guys today's video is
brought to you by upstart.com
so last year i think life showed us that
a lot of unexpected things can happen
oh yeah and i think for most people you
know we use our credit card and there's
probably some sort of balance on there
and when unexpected things happen our
go-to is always her credit card
so what i like about upstart it's given
the whole world a whole nother option
in case of emergencies or other
unexpected things
and i think the thing that i like about
it the most
is that you can get approved the same
day and get
your funds the next business day so if
you are in a bad situation
and you do need emergency funds upstart
is there to help you
and since they go based off not just
your fico score but all kinds of other
things
they can give you a much smarter rate
than any other
uh conventional loans and it takes only
about five minutes
to check out what you qualify for and
it's very upfront and all that and you
can get
up to fifty thousand dollars which to me
is like if i could get that much
that's a whole year's salary for a lot
of people okay
yeah like my mom didn't even make that
much and i'm just like we could live off
of that
for a whole year i don't recommend
anyone do this but
if you had to that can work out right
but i think the main goal would be if
you have credit card
debt if you have other kinds of debt and
the apr is super high you should at
least
check it out and see if the apr is lower
with
upstart and just swap it over because
you know basically it's like one payment
and you're gonna be paying less so why
not do it anyway if it only takes five
minutes
yeah so i think you owe it to yourself
to see if you can actually lower your
monthly payment with upstart
go to upstart.com off the record that's
upstart.com
off the record and make sure you use our
url
because i want them to know that we sent
you guys
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit
income and other information provided in
your loan application
so go to upstart.com off the record
bye-bye did you know mike in college oh
yeah that's
that's how i met him yeah and and he was
uh i lived with him in college
he he taught me a lot of uh where i got
some of my foundation of dance and the
culture
but just like seeing him kind of like uh
in that essence like
to kind of pioneer an ability for like
asians to
go out there and do that that that just
changed the way that we view stuff so
after i started like you know actually
getting a couple more classes now i was
like getting thirty dollars at class you
know my [ __ ] was
that's it that's a 50 you know yeah so
you know
the the world possibility started
opening up and i asked him i'll never
forget to ask him i was like hey man
um i bought five dollars
[Laughter]
i asked him if he thought that i would
be able to
make it as a dancer and immediately not
even like
three cents he was like oh absolutely i
was like you serious
wow he's like dude you've got more
opportunities as a dancer
than some people who like come to la and
work their whole lives for it wow
really and i was like i just got shook
by it and i was like damn that's how the
tree i've like at least still gotten a
chance to
you know ran i even went on like the
tick tick tour and stuff like that you
know
there's that many sorry people that come
here
you know opportunity right um and then
and then after that uh i just asked him
i was like
if i try this do you think you helped me
absolutely
so after that i picked up a restaurant
job started serving like sushi and like
shabu shabu to be able to do a classic
artist
you know lifestyle yeah um and then once
it got to a point where
i was getting more dance opportunities
then i was able to like work
that's when i remember uh my shout out
boss was like
anthony i like you but you don't work
here no i need to give your shifts to
other people and i was like alright cool
so this was the moment
and it was february 2012 and that was
when i was like all right
i'm for real phil doing this i hit my
sister once i got laid off by the
shop of a dude and i was like who can't
borrow five bucks
this is what she actually told me she
was like and you're the only person in
our entire family tree that even has a
chance of trying to do what you love
oh just like so you have to go for it
and
um you have to do it seriously but you
also have to be serious with yourself if
you can't make it to a certain point
you've got to give yourself that
ultimatum
and she told me she's like i would only
be able to help you out until like april
should i kept the girl with me you know
and she's like if you can't take care of
yourself you got to be serious with
yourself
what about me sick come on mate
[Music]
so like 30 days yeah i was just really
fortunate to have people like my sister
like mike to like kind of just keep it
real with me yeah you know what i mean
whether it was inspirational reality
and then um actually it was in that year
that i remember i had you come over to
my house too and i was just like asking
a question i was like yo like
but give me some advice i was just
trying to like think about what
was possible and i was still you know
trying to just just do basic hustle like
anytime i got an opportunity to make
money no matter what no matter how like
you know if i was carrying out some kid
stuff or whatever i was like absolutely
anything else was just like the
guerrilla hustle let's shoot a video in
the parking lots go shoot it on the
grass
you know there's no videographers that
were killing at that time it was always
just like
yo you scratch my back i'll scratch
yours you do this for me i'll i'll
buy you lunch that was the only thing i
could offer you know what i mean so
um that was that was just the hustle and
then from there i was like i'm gonna try
to do this
is this around tick tick tour yeah i was
like right after
at tic toc tour i was not formally a
dancer in profession
i was like given random opportunities to
make money and so they have obviously
mike was sick right and you replaced him
or something like uh lawrence replaced
him
uh because me and mike and victor are
part of uh uh yo mama crew at that time
right mike couldn't make it because he
was doing a lot of
other awesome work and so lawrence ended
up going you know
lawrence lawrence is also a roommate
from college like [ __ ] my brother for
life
so like we were able to you know go out
there and enjoy a
bit of like what it is that somebody
else were able to do to do
damn that was very inspirational yeah my
first impression of you
was you and lawrence were in the back of
the the tick tick tour
bus or whatever you're in and you were
like the car park
and the car park you always shut up
about the car park
she's so sophisticated she's scared
damn she's skated cool hearing your your
background and all that
because that's i mean everyone has a
starting point right to get to where
they are so
well the fans had questions for you
and so i'm gonna ask you some of these
questions
so the first one here is do dancers get
skimmed over if they make
a video that's low quality and and only
consider dancers
potential not only based on the video
quality but their skill
side note if there's nowhere to get your
name out besides social media how do you
compete with others trying to get their
name out there as well
it's like an 18-part question yeah yeah
it's like a lot of dick
that's a good one right they're like
okay okay
um first and foremost i think we live in
a different world
right um before yeah in my mind i would
have been like if you're really really
good
you'll get noticed and i still believe
that but now there's also a lot of
really really noticed and famous people
like for example through the tic toc
generation that like focus on dance
they're not really really good dancers
but doesn't mean they're not really
entertaining or have like a strong
hustle or
maybe they're young they don't have to
like pay bills or have like a job or
anything so they have like hell of time
to do stuff so
you know i i think it's dance as a
spectrum has finally been brought in
through social media
so that people actually understand that
there's like opportunity lifestyle or
like i can be a dancer like uh what's
her name
charlie or whatever on tick tock you can
get like millions of followers by just
doing like dance moves and everybody
copies it so i think we're just in a
different
wild wild west kind of new world where
if you love it there's possibility it
just depends on what it is
about it that you love if you love the
artistry
then yeah like [ __ ] put your training
in and like do everything that you can
to level up your craft
if you love the notoriety then
there's a totally different lane that a
dancer can go down for that you know
what i mean if you love the
social element or the camaraderie then
there's a culture to that that you can
explore
and would you want i want it all
[ __ ] the number one in
everything
i wanted then i think the number one
thing you should do
is get a foundation of talent and then
get as popular as possible as much as
much as like that's not necessarily an
idealism of like
like if i had a kid and i was just like
get as popular as possible i think
there'd be
intrinsically like mischaracter things
that i would be like sharing that
but at the same time if you get
[ __ ] popular you know what i mean
once you have ability once you have a
platform once you have influence it's
like you can kind of choose what you
want to do
as long as you're good enough you know
what i mean i think that there was like
um
a part of me that always wanted to get
as skillful as possible
and then once i started doing a lot of
industry work it was kind of like
there's only a certain
level of skill that you even actually
need because either
digestibility from your audience or like
ability from like
artists that you're creating for or
something like that that shakira can't
move like this
there's no point in moving too good in
essence you can't give
people like if you're like a like a
bible and you're doing like
you know three spins in 1999 you're not
gonna choreograph that for an artist
you know their ability is like true you
know so so same or
for me like i really enjoy like beat
musicality and manipulation
intricacy isolation if i go too deep and
[ __ ] like people are gonna be like
even the audience right they just wanna
yeah like whatever you know they just
wanna vibe so
it really to answer the question or long
story short like you just really have to
find whatever it is that you like about
it and you put enough energy and time
into it there's a profession there
you know what i mean just depends on
what you want from it yeah so
uh how about in terms of like the the
video video quality
and stuff like you as a video clip when
you're looking i was a film major so i'm
like a little bit like
on a high horse when it comes to that
stuff because i enjoy it right i know
casey's not instead because like that's
just what we like to do
um and also like we we were fortunate to
kind of come up in more of a youtube
generation than like a cell phone
filming generation right all the [ __ ]
like
uh in in-app kind of effects
uh and the cut sequences or being able
to overlay music
like none of that was available so like
the craft of even
putting basic uh things together to
create artistry
was part of the joy versus the idea of
like is a high quality video better
in today's world i'm not alive can't
just we make high quality visits all the
time we spend
so much energy and effort getting people
together and like
you know visual effects and [ __ ] like
that but at the end of the day
if i even put just like a woe video on
my ig reels or tic toc
i'm gonna get way more videos on that
than like my hard like
this is my soul in this routine i'll get
like 40 000 views on like my soulful
routine
but i'll get like 150 000 views on like
a 13 second clip of me hitting the world
to like a
baby track that's right so like i i
think that
again it depends on what you want what
you're going for if you want to be hired
for your craft and your artistry then
yeah i think high quality videos are
going to [ __ ] matter
people want to know that you're a
professional people want to know that
you're capable of like
bringing a high quality to whatever it
is that they're hiring you for that
but at the same time if you're just a
cell phone social influencer that
also has a huge marketplace and people
don't really
care about the quality they care about
the
authentic authenticity and the
relatability of that medium right
everybody sees like a portrait mode type
of video
you understand that it's like made for
mobile which is like the highest place
of consumption anyway so
again it just depends on what you're
going for but that's true because like
the the landscape of
of the entire industry has changed and
then
because the next question is asking like
what is some advice you would give to
dancers that would also want to pursue
dance as a full-time career but
as you're saying it's like it depends
like how like which which lane you're
trying to take right
yeah it totally depends well there you
go
what's your favorite part about dancing
the movement
then there's a lane for that you know
what i mean there's like people who are
like just about like dancing so
uh they'll specialize in freestyling
they'll go like win gems and battles
they'll be prestigious by their
athletes and therefore the rest of their
career they're flying around and judging
and teaching battling
because they're they're they're um what
they offer their culture and their
community is their skill
yeah you know what i mean whereas
sometimes people
are with their craft they're not
necessarily offering the skill they're
offering
the um their ability to
create and make something just like uh
is that like a choreographer yeah like
like creating for um
like you know like the family guy intro
mm-hmm you know what scenes and
oh you see it done and then by the end
of it everybody's in this like elaborate
giant spot they're doing the can can
people are doing you don't think about
the dance moves and the choreography but
that's necessary to paint a picture in a
way bigger space
like a musical yeah and there's a
choreographer there and they might not
necessarily be like the front-facing
alien but they have like a very
successful career
and there's hell of musicals and there's
mad theater shows all over the place
so there's a whole lane for people to
like find opportunity it just depends on
like what you love because that's the
only thing you're gonna put energy in so
it's like
the medical industry right you could be
the doctor you could be the nurse you
could be so many moving parts of the
hospital and in the dance industry it's
not just
dancing yeah and there's also different
genres of dance too
like it could be ballet yeah you could
be jazz you could be whatever right so
like
and through social media that's that's
the funny thing it's like what you put
out is kind of like what you're fishing
for right
if we constantly put out like short
forms social media videos that like
maybe
are a minute or less chances are we're
going to get hired
to do a minute or less type of creations
they're not going to be like oh
they for sure can do a movie
you know what i'm saying but if you if
you put out like cinematic
artwork you know you're constantly
pushing the bounds on like your your
output like
we did a short film now it's 15 minutes
or like here's a three-part segment
that's ten minutes each
suddenly they're like maybe netflix is
like oh these guys are episodic creators
so it's kind of like what you put out is
what you get in return since we have
such a
high focus on things like choreography
or like you know
uh i like to think that people love
watching the kindreds for like kind of
our musical flow and our storytelling
through dance to like an entire
track what do you think we end up and
we're asian we get a lot of asian
artists work
you know what i'm saying we do a lot of
choreography submission for k-pop j-pop
c-pop
you know individual artists all in china
and stuff like that so it's like
which you don't think you probably would
have gotten if you just did just
the quick 30 60 seconds one right
because you don't showcase that
that is something that you're
comfortable in doing yeah yeah i think
that um people recognize that
uh there's got to be a relatability for
why you're going to hire somebody you
know
at the end of the day and they're like
hey i really like that choreography not
because of what it looks like but
because
i want to do that so then like somebody
an artist might
hire you you know what i'm saying so it
really comes down to
your interest i think i think we like
being storytellers i think we like um
imagining that we are the artists not
just a compliment to the artistry
you know what i mean it's not like i
hear a song i choreographed to it and
then now i'm a backup dancer to the
vocals
it's like no i'm a visual representation
of it and i think that that allows
people that want to move like that to
feel
empowered through the dance versus just
you know a supplement to
kind of the entire thing i love that
that's a dope mindset this idea of like
knowing how to apply your own yourself
and your skill set
to navigate your career right and kind
of push the needle in the direction that
you would want it to or just to put it
push it in any direction at what point
did you realize that for yourself
because i think a lot of artists
myself included in the early days it's
like i'm gonna do it all right like what
joe is saying
but at some point you kind of have to
reality hits at some point and
basically forces you to specialize or
or at least push in one certain
direction because that's gonna be your
bread and butter that's actually pretty
similar to the next question i have here
which is
what were the steps you took to create
the kinjaz and establish the brand
studios so it's like yeah what were the
what was the
the steps that you took yeah yeah um
i think again like i mentioned earlier i
enjoy creating choreography
um and i also maybe it's because like my
my dad forced me to be a boy scout like
you know for my whole life and he was
the scout master that like started the
troop
i also was like constantly ingrained
with this idea of like leadership
it's like in boy scouts like you have to
be a leader you got to hold positions
it's like the assistant
you know patrol leader the patrol leader
like senior petroleum assistant
scoutmaster you have to hold positions
if you want to like earn rank right is
there a position where
like this is the position for being a
[ __ ]
that was a historian right for us in the
vietnamese scale it was like the
quartermaster the guy who has to like
cook everybody oh yeah a corner master
supporter man hey cooking's awesome i'll
be the [ __ ]
i'll [ __ ] cook all day not when
they're planning everyone's meals though
it's not fun um and cleanup um
but uh i guess i was like always kind of
like
thinking about leadership so any any
organization i joined whether it's my
first dance team
to like you know uh the youth dance
teams or teams i created or even like
hinges and stuff like i always end up
finding myself in like
a creative in a leadership position and
i think that those two things
um kind of like were necessary to
balance out
a skill if i had a bunch of skill but i
wasn't like a creator
and i wasn't like uh a leader then i
think that i would just be really really
skillful and like wherever it is that i
end up going
i'll get there you know i'll do whatever
i do as opportunity so you found your
strengths and put it together and said
how can i combine this with my dance
yeah and then you're like this is where
i fit in as a crew leader and then
building a brand
yeah and and i think also specifically
to the dance game
i would i would venture to say that the
choreographers and the creative
directors
oftentimes have more career uh
opportunities
and and like higher paying jobs as well
because like being a dancer for hire
you can be like illest in the world but
at the end of the day it's like again
like you got to be hard like whatever it
is that skill is needs to be appropriate
for like this particular job
and also might also have to pertain to
like the exterior too exactly like you
look like you feel all of that you know
but
if you're like the creator you can be
behind the scenes and you can adapt your
creation i might always create a certain
way for my own artistry
but it doesn't mean i can't choreograph
for a girl or choreograph for kids or
choreograph for whatever behind the
scenes when i'm not performing
so like just having the ability to
i guess even diversify my own artistry
and artist output
allowed me to like have more opportunity
and even more position as a leader too
because once you're also like
recognizing knowledge as a leader then
you're capable of
you know holding even more
responsibility and having higher
positions and stuff like that so
um that those like you said joe those
kind of things
in tandem i think really allowed guys
like myself
and mike to bring kindreds together
there was a there was a time i would say
in my generation where there was a lot
of us that were flying over to europe to
like teach people would see us on
youtube and stuff like that
they'd like oh i want to learn that so
whether it was like a small studio or a
big dance convention or whatever we'd be
brought out to these random countries it
would be like
you know croatia slovenia or like going
out to like amsterdam coming down to
portugal or whatnot
and there would be times where you know
uh someone's choreographed
choreographers would be flown out there
and then next thing you know we see like
another choreographer in our scene but
we don't kick it all the time
but because we're like in this random
spot we're like oh like you're
also from america or you're also the
only
other asian person in this whole space
and we're gonna be here for like five
days together so i'll take your class
you take mine we're judging the
competition later you wanna get [ __ ]
up at the after party because i wanna be
there by myself
so next thing you know in these random
arbitrary countries you're like getting
super super close with this
very very small group of uh people that
were traveling around teaching
and that's how like um myself and mike
started getting really really close to
people like
you know like ving and ben and pat cruz
and and all these people
and then suddenly you have all of these
shared life experiences in common
and you and you like sometimes are also
like forced like room with each other in
these like small hostels or like
you know like sleep on a train from
moscow to saint petersburg
together and you're just like in these
weird life positions
that you you get bonded in such a way
and suddenly it's like yo we should
you know kind of think about doing this
together more often so we don't find
ourselves in a random country that's
kind of where it started it's like
hey actually if we just kind of like
dance together a little bit more since
we live together back or live close to
each other back home but we never kick
it
in the same community but now once we go
to europe we're like
we're best friends like yeah we should
kick it together more and
if we like work together and dance
together more maybe people will hire us
together more
true so like that started happening and
next thing you know kenja's
like what went from kind of like just
camaraderie
and like hey just like let's like kind
of clan up and you know kind of traverse
life's adventures together
became like uh yo like we started
getting a lot more energy and a lot more
you know
everything together people want to bring
us out as a unit something they want to
put our
our names and our logos on the flyers
and it brought more students and
suddenly we're like
this is a thing huh and not only is the
thing but it's like way more fun than
like going somewhere by yourself
yeah because we were also an early
generation where like you would go
somewhere and sometimes
uh you would teach your stuff and then
people wouldn't pay you or they're like
ditch you and you have to figure out
your way home
you get [ __ ] yeah you know what i'm
saying there's like no oh
yeah do you just go on a promise yeah
you know what it means
so you would always want to be like yo
like i'd rather travel with my boy or
i'd rather travel you know what i mean
in a certain situation i'd be like i'd
rather travel after you deposit your
money
[Laughter]
you know and then and then and with
dance especially in choreography too
choreography is
more powerful when people are doing it
together it's kind of a little bit of
the point yeah yeah
so to even be able to find not only
like-minded and good-spirited people
that were you know about
even your cultural heritage like
understood certain uh experiences lived
experience like the asian american
upbringing randomly in europe that kind
of like unique
niche thing that brought us together
suddenly we're also amplifying each
other's artistry
by like you know dancing with each other
and stuff tight that's beautiful that
was kind of the momentum of kenji's
that's tight yeah it's fun to reflect on
that
it's been a minute
you